Mars is death to spacecraft fewer than
half the spacecraft that go to Mars
survived the landing and so this
spacecraft has an amazing landing
sequence it involves ablative arrow
shells to slow it down as it impacts the
atmosphere at 13,000 miles an hour then
a supersonic parachute deployment rocket
motors to slow it down and the final
step is to lower it from a skycrane 20
feet above the surface on Mars to a
gentle landing on the surface and if it
lands it's got years of work ahead of us
profiling the habitat of life on Mars
the Mars rover behind me is one ton
that's about the same mass as a smart
car on earth except the rover is
nuclear-powered it's carrying a hundred
and sixty-five pounds of science
experiments this Rover has a powerful
laser mounted on its masthead seven feet
above the surface as tall as a
basketball player that laser can
vaporize rock and when the rock
vaporizes a glowing cloud of plasma
comes out of the rock they then use the
very same mirror that was used to
broadcast the laser to pick up the
spectrum of the plasma and find out what
the rocks are made of on the front of
the rover there is a robotic arm it lets
us control from Earth that reaches out
to touch the rocks on Mars to drill into
them with a drill to gather samples and
carry them back to the rover it's got a
brush to brush off the rocks it's got a
scoop to scoop up the soil and on it it
radiates the surface of Mars with alpha
particles it blasts alpha particles from
into Mars and those alpha particles
excite x-ray fluorescence from the rock
and that tells us the elements that the
rock is made of and those elements will
tell us if that rock could be a habitat
for life
the previous Rovers were part of a
long-term plan to look for life on Mars
and they were looking for water they
were looking for minerals that showed
that in water interactions and they
found water completely successful now
we're taking the next step towards life
on Mars and that's to look for the
habitat for life and for the organic
molecules that are necessary for life
and what we learn on this Rover will
help us choose where the best places on
Mars are to go and return samples from